[Music]
hey everybody yes whatever the [ __ ] day
it is it's just day date
[Laughter]
so we're gonna uh talk about
license to kill the double o seven movie
which i don't think we've ever reviewed
i don't think a double 07 maybe some of
the uh we did well we did a show about
the daniel craig ones i don't think that
we've ever done reviewed an individual
movie probably not yeah probably so
we're gonna kind of no i guess we're not
gonna do that here because i'm gonna
talk about [ __ ] living daylights a
little bit too but
that it's gonna it's so quick
that basically with this video i can
basically sum up the whole timothy
dalton 007 thing okay yeah which um it's
good he's good i actually really like
timothy dalton yeah as uh james bond
yeah yeah if you like the new daniel
craig ones you'll see where
daniel craig where he's kind of
challenging the [ __ ] the badassness
of [ __ ]
james bond because it wasn't there kind
of before because
roger before timothy dalton roger moore
had been
james bond for i think many movies maybe
yeah he was in a bunch of movies
he kind of got a little long in the
tooth you know and um james bond was
getting uh pretty far away from what the
ian fleming novels were talking about
which is kind of a [ __ ] cold and
gritty character that could kill you you
know and uh he wasn't described as being
real debonair in any way he was more
like some drunk dude that would be
they'd pull out of a gutter and they'd
clean him up and put him on a secret
mission and
yeah thug in a tuxedo i think that's
what he called him
so
when uh
uh
they retired when they retired roger
moore they kind of wanted to go back to
what ian fleming was talking about so
they
they actually wanted um pierce brosnan
but he wasn't available so they took
timothy dalton and timothy dalton
channeled it he did pretty good
and the first movie was called living
daylights
and i just watched that one a couple
days ago jenny didn't see it with me
though she's seen it before i've seen it
before but it was a long time yeah so i
don't know and i liked living daylights
the theme song and everything was really
good
the first maybe
hour and a half of the movie i thought
was [ __ ] great but then the second
half it kind of slowed down it was
almost kind of like two different movies
put together but it's still good it's
when bond joins the taliban literally
down in afghanistan with the majid and
[ __ ] to fight the russians
uh but the first part of that movie was
[ __ ] perfect i thought
of of living daylights and it was a lot
like
golden eye which i liked goldeneye i
thought that was i thought that was one
of um
oh pierce brosnan's best performances
really
even though pierce brought in i thought
he was good but i don't i kind of think
dalton was better all right i kind of
think so too i kind of wish timothy
dalton had done more bond films because
you know seeing him in this one
he makes a really good bond well he's
believable you could believe that he
would kill you yeah you know yeah roger
moore
i'm not scared of roger
[Laughter]
no he was debiting [ __ ] and kind of
[ __ ] funny but it was it was that it
was getting kind of fantasy i mean he
wouldn't even get [ __ ] dirty hardly
yeah and i definitely wouldn't get beat
up per se you know
so um
but we're talking about
license to kill which is the second
installation it was the last one there
was gonna be a third one but the
franchise got into some kind of legal
trouble and it got delayed and and
dalton had to move on to other projects
he wasn't gonna wait around for it uh
and then they they got pierce brosnan
who they originally wanted all right he
uh he he was hung up at the time with
some other contracts he couldn't do
um he couldn't do living daylights but
they
they got him in on the
the new [ __ ] i guess he made four
right after this one golden eye
goldeneye was good
so was the video game for n64 gold
knives yeah a lot of people still talk
fondly about that damn i want it you
can't get it though though
it's copyrights all [ __ ] up so you
can't get it for xbox one
uh you can get
a remashed version of that game called
perfect dark which is the same engine
but it just doesn't have the bond
[ __ ] theme song and the flare and the
guns and [ __ ] but
that was the first real good first
person shooter
[ __ ] n64 golden eye i [ __ ] want
that game bad
i'm gonna play it on xbox because the
the old n64 controller only had one
joystick on it so you had to do [ __ ]
up [ __ ] with the controls now that you
got two joysticks that game would play
right man it'd be fun anyway
license to kill
can't wait i wanted to address a couple
of comments okay mr88 said uh that he
hated the theme song
i don't like the theme song for this
either it's gladys knight actually yeah
i thought it might have been tina turner
no as soon as i heard it i was like yeah
it's not tina turner it's gladys knight
um the end theme is a little bit better
i think that's patti labelle
but yeah i wasn't really a fan it just
sounded it didn't sound all that bonding
to me like you know what i mean i don't
know james bond theme song has to be
[ __ ] epic and positive if you ask me
like was cinematic and i just feel like
it wasn't all that cinematic like it's
not a terrible song but it's i mean it's
not a great song and even half of the
daniel craig theme songs weren't that
good now i liked all the daniel craig
theme some of them more than others yeah
but i don't mind the slow ones i don't
mind that like as long as it has that
like epic cinematic kind of thing i
don't mind if it's kind of slow the
spectre one i didn't really like all
that much and i definitely didn't like
the no time to die um a
[ __ ] theme song i liked those movies
though i just yeah theme songs
but uh and zach said can we all agree
the way this is shot it looks like a
cheap tv movie because it does i'm
always distracted by how ugly the
cinematography is it's funny because uh
gene siskel brought that up on his
review of this as well because i watched
that earlier yeah um that's the problem
with this one
this one especially the the opening
scene
has a kind of a [ __ ] silly mission
where it's
bond and [ __ ] uh felix
trying to get to felix's wedding and uh
this this [ __ ] drug dealer guy who's
a big threat is escaping and they've got
to [ __ ]
catch him
before he gets away and try to make the
wedding and bond jumps out of a [ __ ]
helicopter with a wire on him and grabs
the back of that [ __ ] plane and then
he
puts a hook around and a wire around the
back of the plane the helicopter pulls
the plane
it's a pretty badass stun
it's all real it looked like it was a
real stuff it really did look like real
so i think most of it is like real
stunts yeah
but now that helicopter would have just
pulled the tail off at ces see that's
what i was thinking i mean that's like a
pretty small plane and i'm like that's a
lot of force you're exerting there yeah
so i'm like that'd probably just snap
the [ __ ] thing right off of there and
then it would just oh well yeah and it
says
cessna is a glorified kite
okay that helicopter pulls tail right
off of it
um
and then they then he they just jump
then they jump
and [ __ ] skydive down and [ __ ]
land right in the wedding and [ __ ]
everybody's [ __ ] yeah they made it
the secret agents made it
[Laughter]
but uh but then the drug dealer gets
away anyway and the [ __ ]
the bad d and felix is now a dea agent
it's not the same felix from um from
living daylights either
i feel like they hardly ever other than
this other than the daniel craig movies
where i think was the the character the
guy that played felix was the same
throughout the whole and that's my
favorite felix yeah he's great i love
that he's the best one but i think in
all the bond movies that featured felix
i think it was a different actor in
every single one if i'm not mistaken and
their characters were totally different
there's no continuity in the james bond
yeah everybody's just kind of like
they're just like whatever as long as
these were part of british culture and
they they came out around christmas time
in december usually and
and they were they were kind of like a
celebration of you know english culture
they're patriotic and hey let's go watch
this badass british guys stop the bad
guys
almost almost kind of but it was
traditional for them you know yeah and
america's got it so did growing up in
brazil brazilians and central and south
americans they got it too they they like
james bond yeah i feel like james bond
but he was universal everybody around
the world didn't get into james bond
and uh it's funny i was in the theater
one time and i remember which one i was
watching it might have i think it i
think it was one of the later [ __ ]
roger moore ones
because those were out when i was in
brazil too and there was a brazilian
woman sitting next to me with her
husband and
roger moore did something he jumped out
of something with some kind of parachute
and the parachute had a british flag on
it it had a [ __ ]
and the woman says
that's not the american flag and [ __ ]
you
guys no james bond's british because oh
i thought he was american
that's pretty funny yeah
they couldn't tell us apart
well you know yeah i guess
i can understand yeah spaniards mexicans
that's all yeah whatever that's what i
mean so it's like if we get mad when
it's done back to us but it's like
british americans who cares british
you're all alike
you know [ __ ] pale [ __ ]
but
anyway um
oh [ __ ] man i lost where i was this
um but yeah the open and then it uh the
opening
scenes of the first [ __ ] 20 minutes
of this movie it's basically taking
place like in florida
yeah like in the kings in the case and
it looks like [ __ ] man they got good
stunts and the decent looking you know
[ __ ] but the way it was filmed it looks
cheap really cheap
but then later on it improves
it starts looking better it's very
uneven looking
um
then it starts getting more exotic
towards the end i even think that that
damn wayne newton was in it he was yeah
he wasn't he was he was yeah i thought
that was wayne newton it was my new year
yeah and it's taking place at this drug
dealer's [ __ ] secret mansion and
they found it's not really a mansion
it's almost like a secret civilization
it looks like a damn
incan temple or something yeah that's a
real place it's like a performance uh
what is it it's like some kind of they
have like concerts and shows and [ __ ]
there i thought it was some kind of
hotel it's in mexico it's in mexico they
shot most of this in mexico and in
mexico and in key west matter of fact i
think this is the first and maybe only
bond film that no part of it was filmed
in the uk because usually they would
film like interiors and stuff at
pinewood in london but there was some
kind of like trouble financially or
whatever they're trying to like cheap
out a little bit on this movie so they
shot even the interiors i think they
shot like on sound stages in mexico
because it was cheaper even though it
wasn't a low budget movie they spent a
lot of money on it 32 million they just
which was a lot back then yeah but it's
just that they should have spent more
uh and i don't think that justified some
of the made for tv look in the beginning
of the movie and it was also the way the
way that things edited is that it's kind
of a muddy kind of a
[ __ ] storyline and it's like come on
man get to the [ __ ] points very
uneven
the way it's paced
um but still
a good performance from bro from um
from timothy dalton
he did carry the role i thought he was i
thought i think he's a real good james
bond he is yeah there was gonna be a
third one but there was some kind of
legal trouble with the franchise it
started to stall and and dalton's he had
to move on do something else you know
[ __ ] gotta make money you know
scheduling you know and i think he i
think after that when maybe he saw the
writing on the wall maybe he thought the
james bond franchise was going to start
maybe going downhill he didn't want to
be part of that i don't know
but there was some reason
probably besides the legal rank you know
wrangling that they were doing i think i
think maybe he lost confidence in it
even though
i think if i remember correctly that
director
who did that
[ __ ] love timothy dalton and dalton
liked him thought yeah john glenn that
guy yeah and he's the same guy this i
think this was the last bond movie he
directed but he actually started out
editing bond movies he did um
he did uh
honor majesty's secret service spy loved
me and moon raker he edited those and
then he directed for your eyes only
octopussy of you to a kill living
daylights and this one yeah and um he
was the one that was kind of pushing
after roger moore retired for
bond to go back to more what ian fleming
intended with the character like more of
like a rough like without so much humor
like more grounded in reality like i
said so in a lot of ways like what
people like about the daniel craig bonds
that it's more like realistic
this was kind of like doing that but
like way ahead of its time i feel like
but i don't know if people were ready
for it this made money
but i think it was the lowest grossing
at least in the us i think it only made
like it's exactly its money back like in
the u.s i don't think people because
this was the first bond movie too that
was
rated pg-13 instead of pg because it was
like super violent and like kind of dark
and he wasn't like this charming funny
kind of character anymore like roger
moore had been like he was actually like
killing people and like [ __ ] people
up and doing things that were kind of
morally questionable like right [ __ ]
pistols to the back of girls heads and
stuff yeah
but you know that's kind of the way the
character was yeah that's what i'm
saying yeah so i'm glad they actually
kind of went back so i really liked that
about it there are a couple of like
funny things in it
but
which in a way kind of tonally or a
little bit strange yeah like some of the
quips that he makes but it's not it's
only like a couple of times that it
happens and like the whole like f first
part like with the wedding and stuff
that was like a little bit weird yeah
like i mean well
because timothy dalton
was such a serious bond and like very
cold-blooded and you know a lot more
violent a lot more willing to get in
there and get dirty and get beat up and
everything like that yes which is really
nothing by today's standards yeah in the
context of the late 80s
yes it was kind of a big deal and i
think like people weren't really into
like especially after roger moore's run
which had been so long it was kind of
more like a silly he was popcorn kind of
movie yeah it was getting comedic i mean
he was yeah
yeah
but this one was like a lot more serious
like i said there is funny [ __ ] in it
but it's not like over the top i kind of
wish there had been like no humor in it
to be honest um it doesn't like distract
but they were trying to please the crowd
in the second one they were yeah they're
trying to please some of the critics who
thought that they'd gone overboard with
the tough guy stuff i was like no they
should have gone even more yeah i mean
yeah way grittier i mean like if this is
this bond movie which i feel like
doesn't happen like hadn't happened
prior uh felix gets his arm and leg
chewed off by a shark and as they rape
and kill his wife they rape and kill his
wife yeah um off-screen like you just
see kind of like the aftermath anicio
del toro's in it he's [ __ ] he's
looking young and good he lit
[ __ ] looking god damn that
[ __ ] was hot yeah i mean he was
still hot like later on but like a real
tough leonardo dicaprio taller but with
dark hair and [ __ ] kind of like a laugh
he looks like a crazy mother yeah he's
crazy
but he's good he's good yeah he's great
in this he's great i've always really
liked benicio el toro and everything
that i've seen him in i had never seen
him in anything where he was this young
i mean he's very very young in this but
yes
the one that got killed she was uh the
girl from 33's company the one that
replaced suzanne summers yeah i can't
remember her name but she's cute but she
got killed she's cuter than suzanne
summers i mean she gets killed like in
the first [ __ ] five ten minutes or
whatever
but yeah and then like a dude's head
gets blown up in the pressurized the
pressure
there's some [ __ ] that wasn't in the
theatrical cut
is in this because they they had to cut
some stuff to give it a pg rating they
didn't want to get the r rating so they
had to uh cut stuff out now i saw that
stuff anyway which makes me think that i
saw this on cable or or i saw it or i
rented a different version of it because
i remember that that guy's head blowing
up
yeah because i think i mean see in the
theater and the thing too is like
benicio del toro's character he's kind
of one of the like main henchmen of the
bad guy sanchez um he gets thrown into
uh what the [ __ ] is that thing oh it's
the thing that like chops crush it's
like a rock crusher that like does the
cocaine like back out of the whatever
and he gets like thrown in there and
like basically turned into like [ __ ]
fine mist yeah they shot him from the
bottom looking all the blood coming out
yeah i think so i think when they
released this to theaters
in the u.s i think they trimmed a few
seconds out here and there like of the
dude's head blowing up in the
decompression chamber of felix getting
his arm and leg chewed off by the shark
um benicio del toro getting like thrown
in the rock crusher thingy and i think
they took like a couple seconds out so
it would get a pg-13 because i think it
would have got an r otherwise and they
really didn't want that because i kind
of feel like as sort of gritty as this
was for the time like i said the daniel
craig ones are obviously like much more
violent and grittier and stuff but this
for 1989 this was kind of like a big
deal and i think that they didn't really
want to alienate
you know a movie that traditionally like
james bond movies like the whole family
would go see it because it's like a fun
like adventure now when you say like
gritty it's nothing as dark as daniel
craig no no no okay but it's always in
the context of the time we were coming
out of an 80s where roger moore this was
like a goofy [ __ ]
[ __ ] double seven was a put on it was
just some [ __ ] it was like a feel-good
movie they it was uh it was fun
uh there was gonna be some uh [ __ ]
sexy chicks in it you know and [ __ ]
people pretending to shoot each other
you didn't really take any of this [ __ ]
seriously gadgets and stuff
wasn't wasn't anything serious i mean it
was really just a couple notches [ __ ]
up above or a little little a couple
notches above in reality above austin
powers really that's what roger moore
did so when this comes in it's
it did
in comparison seem
like a move towards reality
but to see it from contemporary
viewpoint now
it's still very much an 80s action flick
yeah gasoline explosions
they i mean unrealistic gun fights but
there's great stunts in this great just
like the stunt work in this especially
that tanker trailer like uh chase at the
end is fantastic with the missiles yeah
and they have big huge explosions dalton
is doing a lot of some of the stunts or
certain shots inside the studs yeah you
know yeah he's clearly doing
a lot of it right so
um
he's delivering a lot more than [ __ ]
roger moore roger moore is just no way
he's gonna run across the top of a damn
[ __ ] truck well it's going 60 miles
an hour that was a stunt double you know
yeah but it looked like it looked like
pierce brosnan was doing or even look at
timothy dalton was doing that
was doing some of the stuff other than
the real dangerous [ __ ] which i'm sure
they'd let him do he for the most part
looked like he could do
what
they were showing him do yeah he looked
like he was in could do he looked like
he was in decent shape yeah um the first
one you don't really i didn't really get
an idea of what kind of shape he was in
because they didn't they don't he never
takes his shirt off or anything
in the second one he does
they're trying to let you know that he
is in decent shape and he's
he's in okay shape a lot better shape
than say
more was he's in better shape than
[ __ ]
uh uh charlton heston was you know what
i mean he's in pretty good shape
is he [ __ ] on cycle [ __ ] buffed
out in hrd no he's not all right [ __ ]
daniel craig was
daniel craig a 40 looked like he could
[ __ ] whip your ass but he probably
could
even in his 50s daniel craig looks like
he could whip your ass
and he probably could
was he natural no [ __ ] no
same as those guys in the mcu and [ __ ]
you know they're they're on [ __ ]
um
in reality it's more realistic that they
would be on [ __ ] you know special
operatives [ __ ]
delta guys and dudes in sf they're on
[ __ ]
you're not gonna be able to get in those
units unless you're willing to go on
cycle just like any other professional
athlete but they don't have to play by
rules
so they're on [ __ ] you know
um
so i think he should have they should
have done something with him because you
know
sylvester stallone was on cycle they
were doing [ __ ]
from that same era he should have been
enhanced
maybe they weren't as comfortable doing
it back then not everybody nowadays they
they got it down with science they'll do
it
um
[ __ ] every actor will do it uh tom
hardy [ __ ] he's on all kinds of [ __ ]
depending on whatever role roley's got
to do and i i really respect tom hardy
he'll go on cycle or he'll get fat or
he'll get skinny he'll [ __ ] you
down that's got to be really hard on
your body
but uh but he's willing to do it
christian bale does that christian bale
too
oh
he's like he'll get fat he'll starve
himself
he'll buff out
yeah it is very rough on your body you
can only do it like especially when he
starved himself down to for the machine
is the machinist [ __ ]
we still need to review that i love that
movie you had to pay me off god damn he
looked like
that was unbelievable like when i saw
him in that i was like i couldn't
believe he was still like walking around
alive holy [ __ ]
so um
sean well says all respect but roger
moore never even thought about working
out no
well he didn't have to he's like just
bring him by stunt double i'll be in my
truck
what roger moore's [ __ ] strength was
is that um
he was tall
he looked like us like a a a
a male model in his 50s he had a good
face
uh he had a
a very debonair [ __ ] yeah he was very
charismatic he was character talking you
know but that's not going to get you out
of a [ __ ] fist fighter and gunfight
okay and that's really what this guy's
supposed to be about so that's not going
to be a priority
you know
what what [ __ ]
what what [ __ ] ian fleming was
talking about was timothy dalton or
[ __ ] daniel craig yeah he's much
closer to the original character closer
to daniel craig probably okay yeah like
i said he just wanted somebody who was
essentially like a cold-blooded thug
yeah
he was smart but who could but who
cleaned up nice yeah he had good tastes
in things
but he's kind of got to blow money and
also steal money
you know [ __ ] they would you know
they
because a lot of the daniel craig series
and even some of this one i think he
steals money in this one too doesn't he
or he throws some money away well now
that when the dea agent who's played by
the same guy who was in the people under
the stairs um
when he when he basically like feeds
that guy to the sharks because he does
james bond he's he's not just like oh
i'm not gonna do it he's like [ __ ] you
dude um yeah but that dea agent who was
um you know uh like turned on he got
bribed by like the drug dealer and he's
like i got a suitcase right there with
two million dollars in it i'll split it
with you and then bond is like uh you
earned it you keep it old buddy and then
like he throws it at him it throws him
to the shark and he throws him to the
sharks and like so all the money goes in
there and it's like he doesn't even
bother and there's a bunch of money in
that plane that he steals too and he
just kind of laughs and like throws it
out the [ __ ] window the original name
for this movie was called uh license
revoked yeah but they changed to the
last minutes to license to to kill
and it [ __ ] up all the posters and
they couldn't use these
that's why the posters for this were so
shitty like they look really like yeah
slapped together because they were like
they were they changed the title of it
well they changed it because they said
well they only figured out like right
before the release that license revoked
in the united states that means you got
your driverless solutions take it away
now you're lazy
[Laughter]
that's basically what that what the
connotation is well the reason why it's
called that and this one is because uh
to avenge felix he has he goes rogue
yeah he revoked his [ __ ] doubles yes
it's a revenge story yes he's going it's
the whole theory the whole behind this
whole
thing is about
loyalty and vengeance and trust okay
which that's carried on in the in the
craig series there's a lot of that
um
he says basically he says [ __ ] [ __ ]
seek being a secret agent i'm gonna
avenge
my boy so i'm going after these guys
so he gets in with them pretending to be
a [ __ ] out of work [ __ ] assassin
and then he uh realizes that the main
bad guy doesn't care very much about
money he cares more about loyalty
so bond kills a lot of his main the bad
guys henchmen by
setting them up to make it look like
they were stealing money or going behind
his back you know and uh [ __ ] the
main bad guy was killing his own dudes
uh yeah he was talking he was trying to
distrust someone destruct distrust
among the organizations
in the end of course you know but uh
it was a decent kind of confusing in
certain areas like the the edit isn't
all that great like somebody said before
it's very uneven the quality looks
uneven it'd be like low quality and then
real good quality and to go back to kind
of low quality then pretty good quality
and then down to okay
it's not real
even uh textured
i much preferred
um living daylights i saw that one in
the theater when it came out i saw it in
brazil in the theater
and i loved it it's been uh watching it
again i was like oh yeah yeah that was
this movie and i was like oh okay yeah i
remember when i have i forgot some of it
because you know
a lot of bob movies are samey i mean
they'll use the same [ __ ] kind of
tropes over and over again and
they've you know they've made so many of
them they pretty much exhausted a lot of
ideas so they it all kind of seems
familiar a lot of times
and i lose track of what happened in
what movie and what bond did that you
know but going but seeing living
daylights i was i
it took me back i was like oh yeah yeah
okay oh i thought that happened in
goldeneye
because there is a lot of the uh of
living daylights that
felt like goldeneye especially the first
45 minutes
um
out of the two i'd recommend goldeneye
oh golden eyes excuse me out of the two
i'd recommend living daylights it's a
better movie
some people do like this one better
though but like i said i can't really
judge because i haven't seen the living
daylights probably since it came out or
like a year afterward you just watched
it a couple days ago but i haven't seen
it i just watched this one last night
the license to kill which i don't think
i'd ever seen this one before not that i
remember living daylights delivers
everything you expect out of james bond
movie
being in europe
soviet agents cool car cool car
cool car with gadgets
hot hot ladies hot chick
he's saving a hot chick who he was gonna
kill that kind of stuff
um
and then uh
black
suits in a black [ __ ] tactical outfit
jumping out of down
airplanes and skydiving and landing on
top of mountains and fighting soldiers
even if it's just training they show it
you know uh and then secret agents
infiltrate your side and getting into
these gun fights and you only got blanks
you know there's all kinds of good stuff
i mean in
in living daylights i'd take at least
this one though
in its defense
has sharks got sharks and men ninjas
yeah because i was like well i'm
watching it i'm like oh and suddenly
ninjas out of nowhere all right we're
doing ninjas and that's it's literally
like a five minute scene and then
there's no more ninjas and i was like oh
no more niches but yeah and and
exploding heads yeah so it's hard to put
there's so many of these things and i
haven't seen a lot of them i don't even
i've only i don't even remember the sean
connery ones that that well i don't know
it's been years since i've seen some of
those
but um
from the ones that are more recent you
know like in my lifetime
it's among the
the uh
the dalton ones are among some of the
best
i probably put my favorite ones as
casino royale
um skyfall
goldeneye
living daylights
specter i like spectre i even liked the
last jet daniel craig when no time to
die i liked it a lot i liked all the
daniel quirky yeah i think skyfall is my
favorite like all out of all of them
yeah but i but i like all of them yeah
someone say well you know i don't like
that second daniel craig what was it
called quantum of solace no that's one
of my favorite ones actually now that's
my least favorite out of his you got to
watch it but but it's still good you
watch it a couple times and you're like
oh okay yeah it's got a lot of cool [ __ ]
in it it's got a lot of paranormal stuff
happening in it yeah you know it's
better on rewatch i'll give it that but
skyfall is still making a bunch of
bunch of alchemy references happening
about water and fire and burning water
and
people selling water and being forced to
drink oil there's all kinds of damn
alchemical symbolism happening in the
story i liked it it was a very
manichaean story you know
uh which
there are there are some weird
kind of
not paranormal but alchemical and kind
of
paranormal and religious kind of
references that happen i picked up
little themes
in all of them or most of them that i've
seen
there's kind of religious themes in them
but
not
christianity it's
like gnosticism symbolism
i don't know if it's me reading into it
or if it's really there but i don't care
i just go along with it yeah
can i say that like the the one thing
about this one that i don't love and i
did actually like this movie it is like
really entertaining the one thing that i
don't love is i don't really love i kind
of agree with cisco and ebert on this uh
or mostly siskel where he said
well it's like this he's like the bond
movies that have like bigger villains
you know what i mean like dudes that
want to like take over the world
um are a lot more exciting i kind of
feel like because the main villains in
this one were just like a drug cartel
and i think even in 1989 like drug
cartels as villains had been
like overdone i think like in 80s action
movies there's like a [ __ ] ton of 80s
action movies where like some drug
cartel like it's from south america or
whatever we're like the bad guys and i
just kind of feel like i'm not saying
like the stakes weren't high because
they were and like a lot of people got
killed and [ __ ] like that but it wasn't
like a globe-spanning
uh villain network you know what i'm
saying it seemed like a smaller potatoes
yeah by the by the late 80s the whole
drug cartel angle was getting kind of
played out that was that was passe
it should have been something about like
an oligarch using some kind of
experimental technology that was it was
real threatening that would have been a
lot better
kind of like what they did with no time
to die
where uh oligarchs running a world
government were making a damn
kind of a
virus that was uh made out of [ __ ]
what were they they were nanites that
once they got in you
um
they could kill a select person it's a
it was a pandemic that could go through
everybody
but only kill the select individual
people that you programmed that they
didn't kill it yeah so that would be a
fantastic weapon
and then once that thing was in you
they could communicate with it and they
could kill anybody anywhere
but the thing about it i don't know now
that i've said that it's just kind of
like well
you know a drug cartel isn't like as as
i said like globe spanning as some of
the other like james bond villains
i kind of get that they were trying to
again like more ground it in reality so
they wanted to like i guess bring the
scale down a little bit so it seemed
more realistic that bond is just going
after this one particular very powerful
you know drug kingpin essentially um
just to get revenge like for them
you know feeding his friend like half
feeding felix to the sharks and killing
the wife who was also a friend of his
and they kind of like um
well i think they kind of hint too that
he's kind of one of the things that like
pisses him off about it not only the
fact that like they killed the the wife
and felix got his arm and leg chewed off
but was also because of bonds
wife and he was still kind of bitter
about that like they just kind of refer
to it a little bit but they don't like
do any cheesy flashbacks or nothing
willow lee is says hello watching from
south korea and love your cute cat thank
you very much
she is the last name like lee you must
be you must be korean right
she is the cutest cat ever
yeah she knows it too
uh but yeah so
do danny rowling says uh living
daylight's interest seemed like the
intro to die another day but i'm okay
with that
uh zach says also the bond girl in this
bond girls in this are pretty hot but
kind of can't act for [ __ ] yeah i mean i
do kind of feel like the the acting from
the ladies is a little bit weak
um and carrie lowell's lazy eye is so
distracting
yeah willow says she is korean you know
i lived in korea for a year right okay
i liked korea had a good time i was
there
1991 to 92.
robert kitchen says getting over kovad
that [ __ ] almost took me out was in bed
for a week i'm up and walking now love
your guys podcast holy [ __ ] well i'm
glad you're feeling better anyway holy
crap
yeah so i so i kind of feel like like i
said even though this made it's not like
this tanked or anything like that it
made like you know ample money i think
what like 150 million or 160 million
something like that um it didn't make
all that much money in the u.s but like
worldwide it did
but i kind of feel like in the us it had
like a really lot of competition like
when it came out because like you said
they usually come out in the winter time
but don't they usually come out like
around november or like right around
christmas or something
yeah so usually come like right around
christmas like every year every two
years and this one i think came out in
the summer time and i think this was the
same summer this was 1989 right so
that was the same year that you know tim
burton's batman came out that was the
same year that
indiana jones and the last crusade came
out um back to the future two came out
um there was like some other ones too
there was like some other really big
movies that came out like right around
the same time so i kind of feel like
you know those were more like if you're
gonna go see like a family
fun like adventure movie you're gonna go
see those this one was a little bit
grinnier and more geared toward adults
which james bond movies i guess they
always kind of were but
not so much like in the years prior to
this yeah i feel like yeah willow i
lived at uh i lived up above m jim gak
above the mgm river in a place called
cat greaves which is an army camp right
outside palm mun john
where they held the peace talks
my camp you can look it up
camp greaves is now a museum you can do
a dmz tour up there and they'll take you
to my old camp
it was just
first battalion and the 506 the 506 if
airborne infantry only had one battalion
back then and it was the dmz battalion
we stayed up there next to us was
another place called warrior base where
guys would come up there and patrol and
then we had the rock army sectors on
either side of us we worked with the
rock army
and camp greaves
was right next door to a korean rock
army special forces unit known as a
golden bat unit
that's so the golden bats we we work
together with them
okay that's it
uh sasha fred says since you are
reviewing a james bond film one of these
days you should review some of the james
bond parodies like the 1967 film casino
royale yeah we should probably do that
one what year was that one 1967. you've
heard about that one that was the one
where that guy only did that one right
no that was no
i thought the guy i don't think bob only
did one well that was a parody though oh
was it yeah that's what he said it's a
parody film some of the james bond
parody films okay
okay yeah that's what he's talking about
all right because i thought there was
another james bond film
from the from the 70s or the 60s called
casino royale that was actually based on
on james bond
yeah i think there was called i think
his name was called tommy bond it wasn't
quite in this in the franchise i
remember i can't really remember but i
think it was based on something that ian
fleming wrote or
i don't remember
yeah i'm not a james bond expert in that
way it's the older stuff i uh i've never
seen it
mike barrett said this film had to be
cut down for pg-13 because the violence
yeah that's that's true we just
mentioned that earlier like some of the
scenes especially the head's blown and i
think that was cut down and the shark
attack danny rowling said the black guy
that played sharky in this
who also gets uh he doesn't get eaten by
a shark but he does get killed by like
shark hunter so you know um the black
guy that played sharky in this also
plays in the crustle film used cars just
saying
huh
i haven't seen that since i was a kid
i don't think what that uh used cars
yeah i think i like i've only seen bits
of that movie i don't think i've seen
the whole thing we'll watch it one of
these days yeah slasher friends in 1989
is also the ghostbusters 2 came out yeah
that's another one so i kind of feel
like there was a lot of competition and
they released it like at a time of year
that james bond movies didn't usually
come out traditionally and it was like a
little bit and it was like a lot
different than the previous james bond
movies so i think it was just but i kind
of feel like it's gotten
like a reassessment you know what i mean
i was watching um
oliver harper's review of it that he did
several years ago
and in his opinion he thinks timothy
dalton was the best bond um and he
actually really likes this movie i think
he likes living daylights a little bit
better
but
um
you know i kind of feel like this got a
critical reassessment particularly in
light of the daniel craig ones
now that everybody kind of knew because
like in 1989 nobody was like ready for
james bond to go especially the united
states because yeah there's person that
was seeing these in the films seeing
these in the theater they didn't know
about the books
yeah they they they just knew roger
moore and stuff you know like oh yeah
yeah
they were kinda they would watch that or
turn it down
you know what i mean
that was the james bond that they knew
yeah and uh some people liked it some
people did when this came out it didn't
it didn't quite appeal to either
one of those crowds if you liked
roger moore you might not like this yeah
because it's not the same yeah and if
you didn't like roger moore you probably
just didn't even like james bond so you
probably wouldn't have been attracted to
see this anyway
but what they said that they did who did
respond to this were james bond fans of
the books they liked this
and if you see the daniel craig series
which i for me those are the best ones
uh if you see those
um
you can see that what that what daniel
craig is is his channel is channeling
he's actually looking at what dalton did
and going okay and he's i think he's
using that more as a basis and then
adding his own stuff in it
i'll take your i'll take daniel craig
though
another two camp guy said is this the
one with the opening stunt on the back
of that giant dam and bond repels down
to back up no no that's goldeneye yeah
this one yeah that's a that's pierce
bryson here's brosnan and that's a good
movie i like out of the pierce brosnan
movies i take gold and i and that's a
that's just a good
james bond movie in general
and that movie
looks and feels a lot like uh
the first 45 minutes of uh
of living daylights which is which is
adult movie
yeah one of only two yeah i was watching
that adult movie good boy this reminds
me a lot of golden eye
yeah well you know
um yeah no this one starts out with
felix going to his wedding and then
getting waylaid by like the dea like
calling him in for so hey this drug
dealer he's over here and we need to go
get him right now so they do like this
helicopter plane
type uh chase situation and then like it
all ends up with them
parachuting down to the wedding so he
made it on time but yeah so that's how
they do that it's not like i said the
the beginning part of this like the
stunts are good like the helicopter stun
and the plane and everything but
yeah the cinematography at the beginning
is a little
kind of
not like leaves a lot to be desired but
it did like kind of get better like as
it went on
i guess i'm just not used to because
you're so used to like seeing the james
bond movies like in these like really
really exotic locations and i guess like
to me
a lot of it was set in key west and i'm
like well you know i grew up in florida
so florida is not exotic to me
so i'm just kind of like yep that's key
west all right you know what i mean yeah
i'm looking at that because that loses
that is that louisiana because uh we
have there's there's causeways out in
louisiana too so i thought
and jenny was like no that that could be
the keys yeah that's because i'd never
been down there and yeah she was right
because they got like it's like a 12
mile causeway or something like that
because it's just like all those islands
that [ __ ] down yeah i think the longest
one louisiana had was about almost 30
miles it was like one of the longest in
the world well it's like not even
yeah there's one down by the keys but
what a lot of people don't know too is
that there's another big long causeway
over like going from tampa to clearwater
because i used to drive on that every
year how long is that when you think i
know 20 30. i mean no it's not that long
but um yeah i used to drive on that
every day too but so they all kind of
look like that but you don't know what
the causeway is if you're in another
country causeway is is a raised freeway
going over the ocean it's a trip it'll
sometimes make you dizzy as [ __ ]
because a lot of times they're way high
above the ocean yeah
freaky to look down just see the damn
waves underneath you
it's like you're out in the middle of
the ocean well you are you are in the
middle of those middle of the ocean well
especially like if you're dry if you're
driving down to key down to the keys you
absolutely are in the middle of the
ocean
yeah here's going live from island to
island kind of a spooky feeling it is it
feels like you're swaying or spinning
and there's oncoming traffic and traffic
next to you and it's just all that so
much damn motion and it's and if the
weather conditions are are wrong you'll
have a gray
sky with a gray sea
over a gray road
and
with kind of a gray haze and you kind of
get vertigo
kind of like trying to fly an aircraft
at night by using just the the
instruments which i had to do that one
time is just look at the damn dotted
line and keep it on my [ __ ] right
headlight
yeah
because i just felt like vertigo like i
was spinning
yeah it's creepy creepy yeah i was going
80 80 miles an hour
doing that because that's what that's
how fast traffic was moving across it
i don't know how they were handling it
i was in one of those damn was it nissan
cubes or what the what what's the what
was the name of that thing a damn
vehicle was it was somebody loaned me a
car how would i know it wasn't clear
it's damn square
man i think it's called a cube
i don't know when they started making
those so i couldn't tell you that was
when my dad was having bypass surgery
okay so somebody loaned you this yeah
so that was just a couple years ago a
couple years ago yeah okay
slasher fred said the movie jaws has a
reference to james bond in the scene
where hooper is cutting the shark that
was caught open and one of the things he
pulls out is a license plate that has
the double 07 number i don't think i
ever noticed that i noticed that how
clever
that's pretty awesome yeah they're all
talking about the golden eye uh video
game for the nintendo 64. which yeah a
lot of people like really really like
that game i've never played it but
a lot of people talk about how awesome
it was it just had really good gameplay
yeah really good gameplay yeah yeah
all right so do you have anything else
you need to add about the movie all
right so we'll probably wrap it up for
today so tomorrow is wednesday that
means it's our main episode show and
we're going to do like some kind of
paranormal [ __ ] i'm going to talk about
the british
premonitions bureau yeah like i said i
had just heard of
on that william shatner show we've been
watching and i'm like i had heard of
some of this i heard of
the disaster that spurred its creation
but i had never heard about the
premonitions bureau so we're gonna it
wasn't in existence for a very long time
but we'll talk about it anyway uh it
sounded really interesting so i'm kind
of glad that that well it didn't
actually win but the one that won we
already did a show about it and i forgot
so we're so we're doing the second most
votes all right so have a good rest of
your evening you guys and we will see
you guys again tomorrow evening bye